good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday
hope everyone's having a great day i
think you're all having a great day
because it's the first thursday of the
month which means there's a new episode
of the redheads out redheads is for the
early birds we drop around 7 a.m so i'm
sure all of you are already caught up
and it's a fire flames episode because
we read a fire flames book that'll do it
that'll do it and i'm just feeling so
hashtag proud of my hashtag
passionproject hashtag the first
thursday of the month greater than the
first monday in may
hashtag facts hashtag truth serum
um hope everyone had a wonderful hump
day we're on the latter half of the week
so congratulations to you
and everyone around you
your loved ones friends family
colleagues esteemed alumni because even
though we're all so different we are all
operating on the same day of the week
isn't that interesting to think about
it's kind of like the great equalizer
it's thursday for everyone they say that
even though some people like don't work
a typical
monday through friday some people work
weekends some people work like tuesday
to sunday you know but you're right like
some people say that the dead that death
is the great equalizer and while i do i
hear that i hear death and i raise you
day of the week day of the week we're
all just trying to get through a
thursday and we have that in common if
nothing else and honestly suddenly since
you've made that realization i feel more
connected to mankind
sorry womankind
[Laughter]
i feel more connected to womancon too
couldn't i can't even say it i do feel
connected to women kind today yeah
and you know what you know what else i
feel like connected to manholes
why because you know you can't say
manhole anymore what because it's like a
gendered term
but it's like a negative term so why do
we even want one yeah no like give it to
the man it's gross yeah have it yeah no
so what is it called now person hole the
thing is i don't know what a manhole is
it's you know this hole in the street
and the men go down and they fix the
sewage system so women you want to do
that no you want to do it jackie
don't ignore the women who work in
sewage like they're strong and powerful
people that's true they are strong so
maybe for them it's like i'm getting my
ass in this all and all this duty only
to have the word be
manhole you know what i see it i stand
corrected i see it if that is the case
they're making
case closed case closed manhole
cancelled so what is it person hole i
don't know maybe just like a new word
like
lilu we have a human hole i don't know
it sounds like an orifice
it sounds like sexual glory hole that's
what they should call it
um let's talk about what you're wearing
today your today's a cleveland day type
of sweatshirt yeah so i'm just in a
sweatshirt state of mind ever since like
i popped off with a look on tuesday with
my tracksuit i was comfortable and it
looked cute so now i'm just like cycling
through my sweatshirts once again
and that's the thing about me if i like
something i'll do it every day until i
die
and that's why i'm wearing my sweatshirt
i love this today's a cleveland day
sweatshirt it was a gift at one of your
shows and i'm so grateful to have
received it and i don't even know if
i'll need cleveland days anymore i feel
like that's something i can make peace
with now it's behind you now that i'm
living in a peaceful environment but of
course i'll keep the sweatshirt to
remind me of where i came from of course
um
but actually you know what i'm sure
there are bad days in florida i'm sure
there are 100 words just like a
different sort of that day that's kind
of the great equalizer everyone has bad
days yeah everybody makes mistakes
that's so true which reminds me of last
night's episode of breaking bread which
was so much fun thank you to everyone
who joined and got with our time change
next week on wednesday we're going
sticking with the uh time that we
changed to this week because we support
mama's 5 p.m eastern time it is the
season finale of breaking bread yeah
people are they're upset devastated
they're
you know going on strike because
they're forlorn but eight episodes
eighth is next week isn't that crazy
that really flew by it did fly by bruno
is mounting theo right now um it's a
little cousin loving you know what i
find
funny humorous it's like bruno and theo
like can't be bothered with each other
like they're kind of like they're not
like enemies but they're just not like
best friends they're kind of rivals yeah
so like they don't [ __ ] with each other
and now we're recording premium audio
and they start want to like play and
growl like shut the [ __ ] up youtube okay
shut the [ __ ] up
they're so damn cute so damn cute so we
apologize for any you know sickening
audio you guys might be getting
also yesterday um
we
made progress in our journey to
100k youtube subscribers okay and i
think it had a lot to do with us
singling out the sarahs so today i think
until we reach 100k we have to single
out one name and today i'm gonna choose
because i chose sarah yesterday please
keep it like super common biblical of
course today the rachel's okay by the
way i was literally gonna suggest rachel
too rachel if your name is rachel i
listen to youtube or podcast you're
listening right now and your name is
rachel hi rachel hello
i hope you're having an amazing day it's
thursday so how bad could it be now that
we got that out of the way please head
over to youtube and subscribe from all
of your gmail accounts yeah rachel's
yesterday's and the sarah showed up and
showed out our analytics said 816 new
subscribers yesterday like sarah's
check rachel's you're on deck and maybe
we'll make it a competition like who who
should win is it going to be the sarahs
the rachels the rebeccas or the leia's
i'm sticking with the biblical theme no
but then there are a lot of names and
it's all so funny because it's you have
to think of common names for the
toasters so it really makes you think of
like names people were named back in the
90s yeah that's really our job amanda
marissa
yeah
samantha samantha well today we're going
with rachel
emily it's like we're not gonna do the
avas today because that's a 2020 name
and we don't have two-year-olds
listening to the show
not yet
some people listen with their moms right
so rachel's today's your day show
yourself you want you want to get
organized you want to get on youtube
make a gmail if you don't have one
already and subscribe to this
[ __ ] show okay thank you rachel
they love you
wait
thanks a lot rachel thanks a lot totally
the rachel's charge is not charging to
my ipad and he's got used to your ipad
instead of mine
i hope you're happy because i've told
mom
that girl's like chronic iconic and
everyone like pretends to be her
oh i was just gonna say like there's a
like a thing on tick tock where people
cosplay being like remember this viral
video from 15 years ago and it's like
charlie bit my finger it's like all
these classic ones that we grew up with
they're like that's me all grown up like
no it's not i don't think it's them
cosplaying i think it's them [ __ ]
lying you know trying to get be
deceptive and get like followers yeah
because everybody's looking for you know
the moment irish camper who went off on
rachel for using her charger and
when you say like this was me i'm like
oh i'm interested in you but not if
you're a liar yeah people are also
constantly looking for i'm in me mom's
car
get out and become
so there's a lot of iconic internet
celebrities out there just be careful
who you follow like don't get tricked no
do not don't do it um so it's thursday
we've got a great show um
usually what would we recap today oh
beverly hills i'm so behind so behind
but i did get my tv installed in my
bedroom today so we're one step closer
but i'm just loving reading and i have
read now i think it's
four or five five star books in a row so
i am on a roll it started with tom
sagura
then i went to hotel nantucket then a
flicker in the dark and then carrie
white uppercut i finished it last night
and the whole time i was reading i was
like this is really good but it's gonna
be four stars for me because it's kind
of hard it's not like my personal
favorite era and that's just on me but
then by the end i was like this was a
[ __ ] fantastic memoir it is a
five-star memoir and if you're
are you okay i know it's like really
boring
wait what did i say so bored okay like i
told you before the show like i'm having
stomach issues so if you could just like
let me be silent in peace and not like
call me out i'm happy for you like keep
going i said i love that
what's wrong with that and i also found
out that there's better
that's how you that's like what's going
on in the inside they're making and i
told you this part last night they're
making a movie out of her book that's
how good it is and julia fox is playing
carrie white
cure
i'm like
over julie fox completely i was never
under her honestly
yeah no you were never but if she wants
to
do a great job in a movie i support that
percent but the fact that julia fox is
cast in it makes me think it's like um
like an indie like student film you know
what i mean like not a big budget
hollywood moment i don't know i feel
like she's becoming well she hasn't done
anything since kanye yet but she was up
for the madonna
like that's what we heard yeah i don't
know if that was like actually about the
part julia garner mm-hmm
darn
yeah um
no she hasn't really done much and is
she an actress i thought she was like an
artist
i think her uh umbrella of art covers a
lot of categories including actress she
was in uncle gems right no actually i
can relate to that like being an artist
with many talents you know that really
and julia have that in common someone
being like is she a podcaster i thought
she was a comedian oh is she a podcaster
i thought she was an author yeah oh is
she a comedian i thought she was a
singer right she is right above
so the book was great if you're into a
celebrity memoir i actually highly
recommend it and then next i'm gonna
read i think every summer after because
i haven't read it yet enjoy enjoy i
can't wait and i'm excited to read like
a short sweet book not one that takes me
like so many days to finish no yeah no
it's like fun and light and like it
sticks with you i'm like obsessed that i
always think about it also ever since
i've designated my pumping time to be my
reading time that's like
four times a day 30 minutes a day that's
like good reading and now i'm getting
through books and i'm really happy about
that i can't believe we've been sitting
here for nine minutes without mentioning
the fact that like last night we broke
the internet oh my god i cannot believe
like we should start i was like going
through my night until i was going from
reading and i but we should start over
um scratch that
three two one good morning millennials
welcome back theo and bruno shut the
[ __ ] up seriously like you're both
bothering me we're doing a [ __ ] work
thank you bruno come to your mommy okay
so let's talk about last night yeah last
night i'm sitting on the couch we just
ate dinner you just left olivia's house
i'm sitting on the couch like scrolling
instagram and i get a notification emily
jackson is live with rachel parcell i'm
like oh man let me see what my favorite
girlies are up to i just joined i didn't
comment or anything because like i was
being a stalker i was like lurking like
a freak you were a layperson yeah and
then um emily was in la with amy and amy
was like oh my girl no job joined i'm
like [ __ ] how do they know like i was
really just trying to lurk but i guess
like when you have so many followers
it just comes up as a notification so
they invited me up on the live i was on
the live with emily amy and rach parcell
and it was honestly like overwhelming i
i felt like
like there was too many things on my
mind for me to even like i wanted to
like ask them so many questions but then
also like be funny and like it's hard it
was so hard it was honestly like doing a
show like i felt exhausted afterwards i
went to bed right after
um and then i made olivia call jackie
and tell her get her ass on instagram
live then jackie joined the live rach
had to leave in order to make space for
jackie like which was particularly sad
but rach stayed on the whole time like
commenting and like being a part of the
conversation um and it was really kind
of the best night of my life can't lie i
feel so close to the sister scala now
yeah and i'm just obsessed i'm just
obsessed
and i can't wait to have them on the
toast whenever like it all works out
we're in utah they're in florida where
new york whatever it is i can't [ __ ]
wait um it was just a joy and they say
like never go live with your heroes they
do say that but
they're lying they're 100 lying and
we like i think we're successful in
convincing sister scala to start a
podcast at tnn right which a like you
know is a win for the podcasting
industry and obviously it's like a win
for us um but i think it's also a win
for humanity because a sister scala
podcast sounds amazing you know who it's
a woman for
beautiful women womankind
i like how you did that
no it's um it's a win for women who are
actually beautiful
um women who shouldn't have put those
shoes back on the rack because they were
unqualified to do so
yeah that was special that was special
so i'm just kind of like riding that
high
ever since then
yeah it's hard to come on the show and
do the show like knowing that like last
night we were live with the sister scala
and it's like now we're just here with
each other yeah no like
yeah it's just like yeah like it's just
it's not the same it's not like it's not
doing it for me if i'm being completely
the same it's like when we're talking
live with
sister scala emily rach in the comments
no i know it was um
yeah so this is great
having so much fun here
i love the show
[Music]
there's nowhere else i'd rather be
should we call them
literally we got their phone numbers
like we're literally not okay but you
know what's nice and this is how i felt
like with shannon ford like when you
meet someone that like you like are
obsessed with but there's like a mutual
obsession like it's shannon i feel like
i held back at first because like the
way i became like weirdly instantly like
in love with shannon like everything she
did i was like oh swipe up where's that
from like i was being a freak but then
when she came on the podcast she's like
no you don't understand like don't hold
back because like i feel the same way so
there was comfort in knowing like we
were like-minded you know yeah and with
sister scala i really do believe like
there's a mutual adoration and obsession
with one another which makes me feel
like a little bit better yeah no
definitely but you ever feel like you
get really obsessed with an influencer
sometimes and then like five minutes
later you don't care yeah yeah and we've
been so obsessed with rach and the gals
for so long and it never falls it only
gets stronger 100 it's like a it's like
you know i'm gonna say it's like a good
fart it strengthens and lingers
reach would hate that rach would hate
that yeah actually i don't know now that
i follow rach on tick tock like
i heard rachel's doing things on tick
tock i like really feel like i know her
better like she's kind of crazy what
does she do she's just like not what you
think cause like you see her feet and i
think what you know about her if you're
not like a rach stan like us is like
she's really polished like her life
looks perfect but she's like really not
like that she's like hysterical and
she's also like kind of whack like i'm
just that's i think like what the
initial draw was obviously like the
beauty of the all their houses and like
other outfits and everything but i think
the real why we stay is like there's
chaotic energy there for sure oh i love
that but i also love the sisterhood yeah
of course i feel like they're just as
close as us they all work together and
like have the same sort of thing going
on which you don't see so often yeah and
then like before you got there we were
discussing like who's the who you know
of our like us of our family compared to
that okay and like just in in like age
order you're the rage i'm the meg but
obviously i said like i feel definitely
like a rage you know
yeah i feel like i'm an emily
i feel like you're in emily too just
because like you really have your [ __ ]
together
yeah episode is right
yeah that's true that's true but like i
just i don't know but no matter how you
sliced it me is the snitch amy is a
snitch
and to be honest like i don't think
there's like a bad sister you know to
choose it's like not like nobody wants
to be like the emily like nobody feels
that way like i would be happy with
anyone honestly me too yeah but snitch
vibes 100 100
so that was what we did last night just
like we're big fat losers um on
instagram
and that's good because that is what we
are so yeah at least we're consistent
embrace it embrace as they say live your
truth
truths were lived
truths are meant to be lived that is
such a good point canva pro we've got a
great show for you guys today five well
how would you describe the stories i
would describe them as interesting
nothing
too big or too small i would say five
equal stories of interest and will spark
interesting dialogue
i am constantly looking for stories that
are sparking interesting dialogue so i
believe without further ado without
further await sorry no sorry
so tomorrow's friday
general on sale for my shows we've got
okay just listen i know everyone's sick
and tired pre-sale went like amazing so
i'm like kind of quaking for people who
weren't a part of the pre-sale are there
still meet-and-greets left oh no there's
like barely seats left you know
and that's like a good problem of course
no i'm not complaining but like i could
see people being like it's not fair and
it's not fair but you know what else
isn't their life
so we've got uh birmingham there's about
two seats left
we have charlotte we have durham north
carolina huntington long island portland
oregon seattle washington west hampton
new york red bank new jersey
uh new haven connecticut
i think it's like 11 or 12 shows going
for sale tomorrow pre-sale was yesterday
thank you to all the patrons who got
what they needed to do yet to get
tomorrow 10 a.m local time you can check
my instagram and website for all the
information these are the last shows of
this tour of this year this material
will die afterwards don't let it don't
let it because you go to utah
no i know there's like how are the
scholars supposed to see it no that's
fair but like there are about seven salt
lake city toasters like and four of them
are the skulls right so um
i just don't think like i'd end up
losing money on my flights you know
yeah okay fine
yeah maybe if they're like if the utah
toasters like if there are more of them
they want to kind of unionize and make
themselves known because like basically
people are like how do you choose like
what cities like the data i'm like no i
literally looked in my messages and like
i get a vibe of where i need to go like
i was right like nashville tickets sold
amazing charlotte tickets sold amazing
like i know so either there are no
toasters in utah or they haven't like
galvanized yet got it okay galvanize do
it organize yeah petition because i
would love to go to utah same um and
accompany claudia
any excuse any excuse to go to utah
okay so now without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
beauty counter beauty counter is a
leader in the clean beauty industry with
the collective mission to get safer
products into the hands of everyone they
believe that beauty should be good for
you this is why they created a variety
of clean skincare and beauty products
such as the deuce skin tinted
moisturizer their daily makeup meets
skincare tinted moisturizer with spf 20
provides sheer lightweight coverage for
a dewy luminous finish it helps achieve
even looking skin tones and it protects
against sun
the sun's damaging rays they offer an
all bright skincare line which contains
their best selling all bright vitamin c
serum triple acid aha toner and all
bright facial oil
this line supports an even skin tone
helps improve the appearance of dark
spots and it brightens your skin another
one of their best-selling products is
their obsessively clean mascara which
achieves ultimate lift length and volume
without potentially harmful ingredients
best of all is the countersun daily
sheer defense for face and body with spf
25 it guards against the sun's damaging
rays with spf 25 facial sunscreen
formulated with non-nano zinc oxide it
provides a broad spectrum against uva
and uvb rays
right now they're offering 30 off your
first order in case you need another
reason to switch to a clean routine um
clean makeup is obviously like premium
for a multitude of reasons but the
tinted moisturizer from beauty counter
like is that [ __ ] has always been that
[ __ ] and will forever be that [ __ ] i
love a good tinted moisturizer but i
have a really hard time finding ones
that aren't oily or like totally dry um
and i really like the beauty counter one
in addition to the mascara they have a
lot of great products so if you want to
use code toast to save 30 off your first
order at beauty counter that's 30 off
your first order code toast at beauty
counter today's episode is also brought
to you by
better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life well that's how our brains
work so why don't we treat them that way
taking care of your mind your body your
spirit is really important therapy is a
great way to do that and better help is
a really accessible easy way to get
access to affordable mental health care
better help is online therapy it offers
uh video chat sessions phone sessions
even live chat therapy sessions you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to you have to wait in an
uncomfortable waiting room it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours so you can just get
started immediately if you're not
connecting with your therapist which is
really common you can hop around a
little bit before you get comfortable
which is also really common and it's
just an important thing to do take care
of yourself and our listeners are
getting 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
toast that's betterh-e-l-p-com
slash toast
great thank you so much you're welcome
what can i say except yeah welcome okay
our first story adele and rich paul have
moved in together and daily mail has all
of the financial details of course they
do
daily mail is saying this is daily mail
no wonder adele needs to make her vegas
gig work the singer has taken out a huge
38 million dollar mortgage on her new 58
million dollar la home she'll share with
which with rich paul
saddling her with monthly payments of
more than 200 000 a month jesus but
she'll soon be earning a million dollars
a night in vegas you know what i find so
interesting
and i feel like i come back to this a
lot do you remember like years ago when
chrissy teigen did a q a on twitter like
what are like logistics of fame that you
guys are curious about and somebody had
asked her about like mortgages and i
just assumed like if a celebrity bought
a 58 million dollar house like she just
put down 58 million right like adele is
worth 183 million dollars so she could
buy a house out right with that money
right so but then chrissy teigen was
like no actually like the same way like
a layperson would get a mortgage we do
it too but obviously the numbers are
just higher and i just never really
thought that like celebrities got
mortgages so i found that interesting
and now that i know that this doesn't
surprise me that much but at first when
i read this headline like daily mail is
making me like worried over adele's
finances because two hundred thousand
dollars a month is a lot because it's
the property taxes plus the mortgage
payments plus interest rates are now at
five percent but they do have this panel
in the article called why the mega rich
take out a home loan rather than pay
outright and basically uh the investor
feels that what they're paying on the
mortgage is less than what they can do
with that money by investing right right
right so by her keeping on hold on that
38 million million she'll put it to work
for herself you know rich people like
never use their own money yeah
it's so interesting gotta start doing
that i'm so sick of using my own money
it's like sick it's enough disgusting
it's just so unnecessary the house that
she bought was bought from sylvester
stallone and he initially listed it for
110 million dropped she got a deal
dropped it to 85 million then dropped it
to 58 million it's huge and the backyard
is just like everything gorgeous yeah
you're ever hoping to see on an episode
of the kardashians and like it's really
cool but like it's literally a house for
three people like
rich does rich have kids
not that i know of but in her kids it's
a huge house it's like obviously i'm
jealous so that's why i'm saying this
but like it seems like a little like a
lot you know a lot yeah yeah like a
little overboard but you know what like
i can't lie that was me like and i had
three people living in my house me ben
and theo like i'd get a house bigger
like that's bigger with a bigger yard
for theo yeah so um i find the the
intricacies of like being rich and
famous really interesting and it's just
cool you know no one else is a great
equalizer mortgages
so how many shows is she doing in vegas
i thought it was like a weekend
is it like an official residency it's
not an official residency
like you know
wayne newton right but it's more than
travis scott got it got it they're just
calling everything a residency these
days so it's hard to know like who's
donny and marie mm-hmm and who's you
know
kelly clarkson scheduling five shows and
never doing them because of covered yeah
we'll never we're not still upset like
we won't forget and we're not upset you
know like i never got my money back from
ticketmaster but like we are not upset
yeah i'll never get back like the
excitement right forth towards it you
know
all of the memories i was to make i'll
never get those back or my delta uh
flight right because that was that was
before code like officially started so
they were like not being generous yet no
and like everything is just credit and
it's like well i don't want to fly your
disgusting airline anyway so what do i
do with this credit right so give me my
money back once and then the credits
expire in two years and like are you
gonna make it better in two years right
what what will be different in two years
will there even be a flight for me to
book not to make you know adele's new
house about us but even if there is a
fight for me to book for somewhere to go
are you going to cancel it and then i
have another credit right no the credits
it's a vicious cycle it's a vicious
cycle like
do better to educate yourselves these
airlines are honestly like embarrassing
they're an embarrassment to the country
i completely agree and they're so
uneducated 100
also we didn't talk about um spirit
airlines and jetblue merging so i mean
it feels like loser on loser merge no
it's not i watched tpg's episode of the
toast where he explained that this is
good for the customer i said the same
thing to brian i'm like what who cares
if two losery ass companies like get
together to congrat one you know loser
conglomerate
and he was like it's not like that at
all like you have to understand like why
jetblue sucks is because like they're
not a big enough company yet to have
this whole fleet of airlines and that
only happens when you get acquired or
you merge with someone so when he
explained it i was like oh i'm actually
really here he said it'll make spirit
better and jetblue better so i was like
oh maybe i am here for this merger um
i'm here for what he explained which is
extremely trepidatious because nothing
in the airline industry is getting
better right you know things are only
getting maybe things have gotten worse
before they get better and if you guys
are interested at all in like travel
listen to the most recent episode of the
morning toast with brian kelly when he
filled in for jackie one day like a
couple weeks ago um it was really um eye
opening because at first i was like
literally lose around loser crime who
[ __ ] cares and he was like you should
yeah and i just assume like whatever is
moderately good about jetblue will be
like taken down by spirit um
but it sounds like no so i'm optimistic
sure but it's like if delta can't get it
[ __ ] together united american like why
are these two blues there's no hope
to save us right right right never know
spirit airlines they're the ones to save
us we love an underdog story like maybe
maybe this is how it all ends here's the
thing i i want nothing anymore i know i
want nothing more for someone to come in
and show the airline industry how it
should be done
but i'm a realist yeah fortunately
that's my cross to bear it's super
important to be based in reality i
really believe that yeah but i mean yeah
it is but there's also it's important
for some people out there to be idealist
that's how you know
dreams get accomplished look at elon
no that's true but i don't think like
elon is a
what'd you call him idealist no because
like elon is like smart and like in like
in science like you have to be the best
you can't just have like big dreams you
know you have to be like practical it's
merit based yes there's like yes okay
hollywood like not everyone in hollywood
right now is the greatest actors and
actresses of all time they're just like
the ones who got lucky you know it's not
necessarily merit-based
yeah
yeah that's something else right other
than being real but sure yeah agreed
are you ready for our next story which
is something that we talked about on
breaking bread last night that was so
much fun that we actually need to talk
about on the show too selena and jeff
selina and chef season four is dropping
and where was this season filmed the
house from hannah montana season four in
malibu also known as hannah montana
forever hannah montana forever's house
that's a gorgeous beachfront that if you
see a picture of the house you can hear
the house say oh
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah wait the house was also previously
uh featured on hbo's big little lies as
the home of reese witherspoon's
character
did i miss her probably because that
show was like filmed in a different like
in a filter you know but also like let's
be real on hannah montana they never
showed the house they had the one still
image yeah that they used every single
time like from the outside like a little
bit to the side so i don't think we
actually even know what that house
really looks like but we'll know on
celine and chef yeah
what an iconic house adele should have
bought that house and what about the
house that she grew up in the regular
house on the beach
the first one the first one
did that house ever get famous
that felt like a set because they would
only really hold on
no they did the same exact thing as they
did with the mountains
zoom out because i feel like they
wouldn't show the porch
no they would show the back of the house
like with the beach okay she always
lived on the beach you know she was a
spoiled brat
um and she was extremely privileged and
she
like it's literally like nepo baby
nepotism at its finest her dad was billy
ray stewart she was also like working in
the bread earner in her family the bread
winner
not really like
she
was working and making money but like
she came from an extreme not us
literally canceling out of montana she
came from like an extremely privileged
background like she wouldn't have gotten
the opportunities that she got if it
weren't for her dad billy ray stewart
um
and it just makes you think you know
about nepotism yeah she's definitely a
nepo baby but not without talent i think
that's just what you were saying like
it's definitely luck other than a little
bit of merit yeah
and i'm not saying that she's not good
i'm just saying like
what about you know all the doors that
were opened for her yeah and doors that
weren't open for others again i think
that's kind of a conversation a piece of
the conversation that's missing when
dissecting hannah montana how she should
be canceled right now
and kind of you know what let me take it
even further miley cyrus in general
because it was based on truth you know
her dad is billy ray i guess i'm
confused his bobby bobby ray
um dora's open for miley and her brother
trace
um
and the sister right and i just think
you know nepotism is disgusting damn no
i say all the time like when actually
when it comes to nepotism like
i don't have a i don't have a blanket
feeling about nepotism whether it's like
good or bad i don't care it's like tell
me who we're talking about and i'll tell
you if i don't like nepotism but i'll
tell you why that is for you because
whoever we're talking about it's like do
they have talent are they
worthy you know or are they just where
they are because
right let's throw out some popular
nepotism well people are talking about
this now because haley bieber and
gwyneth paltrow did a youtube video
together where like haley was just
basically like what do you say to that
cuz like i get it all the time too
um and gwyneth was like i mean i it was
a classic answer she was and gwyneth is
a queen like gwyneth could literally
fart in my mouth and i'd be like genius
she said you know
of course we have to acknowledge like
you doors open for you much bigger and
faster
the access you get is very real and then
once you get in the door like you have
to work 10 times harder than everyone
else like to prove yourself and everyone
like rolled their eyes but that's what
she said and haley was like no i totally
agree
i
do agree with that i think yeah doors
open but then like once you're in the
door like you need to perform yeah and
for real like for someone like gweneth
like she is talented she's because of
her like yes maybe the first role or
maybe she had an easier time getting to
where she is but like she's there she
won an oscar like i agree gwyneth is
like a talent he's talented but i just
like i think a good example is dakota
johnson because she became the face of a
billion dollar movie franchise without
ever having acted in her [ __ ]
life like i had never heard of her until
she got cast in 50 shades and i have
been to really like dakota johnson like
i think she's hilarious i actually like
a lot of her work but like by no means
is the career that she has like is she
even remotely deserving of
like that's just and that's on being
honest you know
yeah and it but it doesn't bother me
like some of it's still like some
people's like irks me
dakota doesn't bother me because
honestly she's [ __ ] funny and like i
just i like her oh that's you you never
see the video you like her do you ever
see the vogue thing about the limes no
so she did 73 questions and they like go
into her kitchen and she's like playing
with like this bowl of limes and she's
like i just love limes like they're my
favorite like i just love them and it
was like such a random thing to say
and then like it came out a few years
later like she's actually allergic to
limes and they were like she was like i
was just trying to be sarcastic because
like they put this fake bowl of limes
like they set they staged my kitchen and
it was so [ __ ] weird so i was like i
love live that's so funny you know she's
funny like i'm telling you she has like
a really good personality and so i
actually really like her but her career
is like beyond for someone who has like
no experience yeah that's not
just the truth like i feel that yeah
anyways back to celine and chef um back
to canceling hannah montana back to
canceling hannah i'm glad that the house
is like getting recognition and that
selena i think we should watch her show
since we're obsessed with her also she
was spotted on a yacht like with a man
oh let's talk about that does she have a
man's you sent me a picture um paparazzi
picks italy
jumping off a boat like so typical celeb
um with this man who honestly like
wasn't that cute but he was like
handsome enough um and he's a film
producer
and they looked they looked to be like
romantically like linked yeah
it's not what i said i expected for
celina honestly i'm happy for her that
part of me is like i wish it was you
know someone we knew and like we could
get excited but that's literally what we
said like she should have businessman bo
and that's really the only downside to a
businessman bo is like we
can't get excited no to be honest like
the selection i'm fine with like i'm
just like a deeply shallow and
superficial person like selena is like
top 10 most beautiful women in hollywood
and like i just didn't think the guy was
that cute but i'm just like a shallow
person like maybe he's an amazing
personality like maybe he's kind
generous caring loyal funny but i don't
know that all i know is a picture that i
saw where i didn't think he was that
cute okay i'm looking there's literally
he looks like so european you can't even
see a picture of his face wait no tap
his instagram and then
the picture tagged his instagram what's
his name tells his name andrea andrea
what irevolino so italian maybe it's not
like i think he's so cute
i think he's cute but like
not the cover of forbes no it's good
italy but this is everything you could
want for her you know it's good it's
good it's just like i wish she was like
a little cuter like i don't think he's
crazy
not the pope the pope is selena catholic
because that would mean a lot to her
yeah i'm sure it was that picture i know
this is like a really obvious statement
like the pope is such a big deal on the
left that's handsome
oh that's a cute picture yeah the
picture that's an old picture the pope
is yeah the pope is such a big deal like
people like cry
like if you met the pope like would you
care because we're like not catholic
oh i mean
sitting here right now i could be like
no i don't really care to meet the pope
but if i'm terming like if i'm at the
vatican i'm in rome and you know all the
history and this and that and like and i
had the opportunity to mean the pope and
like i know so many other people would
want that opportunity like i would
think you know it was a big deal if i
had the opportunity to meet the pope
like i wouldn't take it because like
like i'm not deserving i would give it
to like a catholic toaster you know yeah
no if like if i knew it ahead of time i
had this opportunity i would give it to
someone else but like you know if i was
just having dinner in rome and like the
pope was next to me right which i think
happens all the time he liked my purse
and he started talking to me right i
think i would be like wow that's really
cool those like few weeks a couple years
ago where
the vatican was trying to figure out who
went on the pope's instagram and liked
that only fans models bikini picture
that was like some of the best time of
my life
i just think like nothing will ever it
gives like suez canal vibes like that
story was so funny and of course we
never got down to the bottom of it
because people just moved on but i still
think about it and i i still like it
keeps me up who liked the photo it was
obviously the pope yeah even though it
obviously wasn't the pope because he
definitely doesn't run his own instagram
or like care to be
he definitely has a fin stuff right it
was some like you know
low-level archbishop who is like young
and was tasked with running the social
media and horny of course yeah i mean
wouldn't you be it was a low-level
archbishop for sure for sure it was
definitely not archduke franz ferdinand
no it was not pope francis no no no
what's the pope's name
francis this one i think so i can help
never keep up with the popes pope
francis yeah
they've elected a new pope i love that
line from euro trip
it makes me laugh i posted it on my
instagram one time when like ben was
barbecuing and there was like smoke
coming out of the grill and i was like
they've elected anu
it's really not funny claudia like
actually no it's literally hilarious
yeah um how many popes have we lived
through
how many presidents have we lived
through i was a clinton girlie right
yeah i was born in november at the end
of
hw so god you're so old h.w he had two
more months before clinton took office
oh my god wait no i'm sorry yeah yeah hw
wait that's like
so great because 1992 was an election
year right yeah oh my god that's like
the craziest thing i've ever heard yeah
no and like he might have already been
like bill clinton they might have won
the election already but he still had
like two months till january no like you
were born in the hw like that is like
not to be just like you're [ __ ] old
you might as well said like you were
born like gerald ford like that's crazy
because to me like maybe it's because i
was born then but like the current slash
like recent presidents like start with
clinton yeah no i and i'm a clinton baby
for sure yeah but there's a little hw in
there i am that's so crazy
olivia's like a whole year of age oh
he's like a reagan girly
it's giving reagan energy oh my god have
you seen this monica lewinsky beyonce
thing oh no what okay so also there's a
beyonce kim thing did you say no okay
it's not a big thing but you know how
beyonce is now out here changing her
lyrics and stuff
um and so monica lewinsky tweeted like
and what about you know
let me find her exact words
beyonce has a lyric about monica
lewinsky and the new album or previous
one the previous one um like lewinski'd
all over the dress in partition
oh and so she tweeted feminist of her
she tweeted monica lewinsky
um
about the story that
beyonce changed the lyric um while we're
at it dot dot
partition
okay i mean she's not wrong like that is
like really mean especially like i not
just like i recently watched um
impeachment it was so good and like it
does make you feel bad for monica um
so it's not very like women lifting up
other women energy from beyonce but like
part of the reason like i love beyonce
is like she doesn't give a [ __ ] like oh
i upset monica lewinsky
okay
but there is a lyric going around that
people think is about kim did you see
this no not yet but let me finish the
story because people then were quick to
like be like monica lewinsky has been
like out here for years you know being
like i'm in rap songs i've inspired like
all of these things and then she's like
no that was like my way of coping with
it oh please also she said like it
should be like bill clinton all over the
all over the country
um
and it just is interesting but what i
was gonna say was
i didn't watch impeachment so maybe i
just
didn't
you know have this experience yet but i
do feel like impeachment was meant to
like be justice for monica lewinsky the
show and maybe for the people who
watched it they now like feel more
warmly towards yeah but it wasn't this
like universal thing of like she's still
just like monica lewinsky you know wait
sorry to say that again i feel like the
show was like
should have transformed like the
narrative when it should have been like
this whole big conversation like justice
for monica lewinsky now she'll be like
on the cover of vogue and like all of
these the show i don't think was that
popular but that was the intended goal
for the 10 viewers and after watching it
i definitely was like oh my god
literally like bill clinton is an animal
disgusting she is like an innocent girl
who like got carried away and like
honestly like if i was an intern and
like the president wanted to [ __ ] i'd be
like okay like you know what i mean like
she was very um
easily influenced by him like he was
literally disgusting and like
yeah no you definitely walk away from
the show being like wait justice
veronica lewinsky and then it's not even
it's of course everything that went on
with bill but then it was like
everything that went on afterwards like
literally just being like labeled like
the nationwide [ __ ] like and like
everyone knowing details like the cigar
on the dress like it's like so
embarrassing for her yeah and i so i
thought that the show would like totally
revolutionize and i'm sure for the
people that watched it it changed how
they thought about her but it wasn't
like this nationwide no but there was
like a change in the conversation for
all of 30 seconds but again the show
wasn't that popular that it didn't like
change the narrative completely but i'm
sure she's really happy with it because
i think she would say that's like an
extremely accurate retelling of my story
she was like a part of the production
team and stuff got it um but there's
also a beyonce that people are saying is
about kim and like it's honestly really
upsetting me because it totally is about
him um here's the tick tock that plays
it ready
uncle johnny made my dress that cheap
spandex she looks a mess
who's uncle johnny i think it's like a
designer like uncle johnny made
beyonce's dress like sickening she wears
spandex cheap looking mess like that's
skims is like spandex
so it appears as though like the kim and
beyonce of it all never makes sense to
me because like everything would lead me
to believe that like they don't get
along with each other like beyonce
doesn't [ __ ] with them but beyonce is
like always sending ivy park
pr packages kim is always supporting
those packages so i don't know you know
how beyonce does that birthday thing on
her website like whenever it's a
celebrity's birthday she does it for all
the kardashians like
i don't think it's about kim i think it
could be about like literally anyone
wearing cheap spandex looking a mess
right and i think people just assume
that and that's kim's influence like
when you're talking about spandex you're
talking about kim because like she
invented that whole like look but
everyone wears it now
yeah i don't think it's about kim either
i don't think so at all i think spanx is
a very popular material and i just think
it's about like so look cheap some [ __ ]
beyonce was like mad at who was probably
wearing spandex yeah or you know
whoever wrote the song with her that's
what i always have to remember like
sometimes i'm listening to a song and
i'm like wait this artist feels this way
about his wife and it's like no honky
tonk
right i was actually thinking about luke
combs that's so funny it's like someone
else wrote it and they collaborated and
it's like not that deep well that's
true if that's before
it is that deep yeah no i think beyonce
like is coming over every single one of
her lyrics like it's her
personal experience yeah actually like
that's another story you see diane
what's that um
songwriter's name with like the chris
jenner here dan warren yeah um she like
she's in trouble she's getting cancelled
she was like can someone explain to me
on twitter and i think she meant it in
like extremely genuine not snobby kind
of way okay can someone explain to me
how it takes 24 songwriters to write a
beyonce song because i guess one of
beyonce's songs from her most recent
album has 24 songwriters on it and
people were blowing her up um and the
reason why it has 24 songwriters on it
is because beyonce sampled a bunch of
music therefore making the people whose
music that was songwriters on the song
okay cool and did someone just explain
that to you know when she was like she
was i really believe i don't think she's
like a malicious person i think she was
genuinely asking um and she learned real
quick real quick what the answer is okay
well at least there's like an answer
yeah
now i know but i do agree with you like
i think sometimes when people like
dissect certain um
celebrities music they need to like just
remember like
most celebrities do not write not
celebrities most musicians do not write
their own
music if they're like mega pop stars
like ariana grande like you always hear
like um
samples of
no tears left to cry or god is a woman
like oh here's camille caballos it was
almost her song like certain songs just
get passed around also
have you been i'm sure you don't there's
like a leaked addison rey song okay um
that she was never released that never
released but like somebody leaked it on
tick tock and it's so good my nails to
die for my hair to die for it's called
to die for it's so cute and then there's
like this um
[Music]
now like more leaked music of addison's
is coming out and she recorded this song
it's a lady gaga song that lady gaga
like tried to use a bunch of different
times like an art pop and it just never
worked for her and um addison recorded
it it sounds so good it's called like
you know nothing but the radio or
something and literally like addison
right needs to release it i'm telling
you addison ray's like the face of the
music industry
my legs to die for why won't she release
it i don't know she doesn't even
acknowledge the fact that all this music
is leaked right and it's on tick tock
which is like her domain it's so good
come on
where have you been yeah like obsessed
is so good
so good it's gonna be addison is one of
those musical artists who's not
appreciated in her own time no and movie
star 100 movie star okay we need to get
to the next story because we're only on
story number three okay is it the next
story that's brought to you by babble
yeah yeah it is for all of your summer
travels whether you're going abroad or
staying domestic and want to immerse
yourself in the culture now is the
perfect time to start babble babble is a
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions and thanks
to babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination so we
know everyone is going like to europe
they're doing their italian summer i
went to italy a few months ago and like
the weeks prior i did do like a couple
babble lessons because i know zero
italian and i just like don't feel like
super confident and safe when i travel
to a country not knowing like the basics
like right left
thank you good night like you just need
to know certain things and babbles
right babel is a great tool for fun and
easy learning babble only requires 10
minutes to complete a lesson so you can
start having a real-life conversation in
a new language in as little as three
weeks other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 150
language experts you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german and there are
so many ways to learn with babel in
addition to the lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes and it comes with a 20 day
money back guarantee start your new
language learning today with babble
right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
tmt that's babble
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com slash t-m-t as in
the morning toast for up to sixty
percent off your subscription babble
language for life our next story days of
our lives is moving to peacock after
nearly six decades on nbc you guys is
the changing of the guards days of our
lives has found a new home at peacock on
wednesday nbc announced its long-running
soap opera will be moving to its digital
own platform after airing the show for
nearly six decades so it's like it makes
me sad yeah it's like it's truly the end
of an era just like end the show i mean
people love it though so why can't it
stay on nbc like the people who watch it
don't want peacock i just don't know
like what's going on with like cable
like they don't know what's going on
either like
i saw the dumbest jimmy fallon video on
tick tock today that obviously performed
well on tick tock but it was like him
and jane fonda doing like a song music
video oh my god i saw it too and it made
me set i'm done with coastal grammar it
was all about coastal grandma which is
like what the [ __ ] do people who watch
the tonight show on cable know about
coastal grandma like it was just like
really kind of indicative of like this
like
i don't even know what the what the
phrase is like it was it's indicative of
like
how cable networks like just missed the
mark on everything it was so cringy yeah
no and they've ruined coastal
grandmother
they really thought they were like doing
something
it made me upset yeah it was cringy as
[ __ ] and i'm sure jane fonda was like
what the [ __ ] is this like she's
probably been going on the tonight show
for like 75 years and she's like oh i
remember when it used to be a normal
talk show where we would just like sit
and
talk yeah it was so weird yeah what was
the story oh they're moving i mean i
feel like that's definitely like at the
end of an era
um i've never been a soap opera girly
but i also like don't understand peacock
why like i just feel
like it's
like this wasteland
of nbc and their like affiliate shows
it's like it's for shows on their way up
and on their way down i think like it's
uh also an emerging
platform and it's also now they have
love island u.s yes and
it is kind of random and it's also
random when places are like okay we have
our cable network and then we have like
our bonus content it's like the morning
pictures on the patreon
um but i actually like peacock i just
feel like this is kind of sad because
the people who watch days of our lives
like don't want your [ __ ] peacock no
and like days of our lives and the soap
operas air at such a unique time like
it's not like they're competing for a
daytime three o'clock slot like just
leave it yeah they're gonna place the
nbc news daily in that slot now oh great
i can't wait to watch yeah like this is
dumb honestly
cable is just like so
like lame to me
lame it's giving lame energy yeah
our next story
the least lame person jennifer coolidge
is saying is talking about all the
action she got after playing stiffler's
mom oh she says i slept with 200 people
thanks to the american pie milf roll wow
so while jennifer coolidge is also known
for her role in legally blonde and most
recently in white lotus the six-year-old
told variety that american pie brought
her more satisfaction than just fame she
said i got a lot of play at being a milf
and i got a lot of sexual action from
american pie there were so many benefits
to doing that movie i mean there would
be like 200 people that i would never
have slept with
that is so crazy i guess that makes
sense like she really was like america's
milf yeah so i didn't really ever sit
back and think like how that must have
you know affected her social life yeah
but the fact that it did makes a lot of
sense and that she embraced it she's
just a queen like yeah
she is one of my favorite like things
about jennifer coolidge is how she
acknowledges so much of her recent like
resurgence to fame has to do with ariana
grande
and like getting like a younger
generation of people obsessed with
jennifer and i think that's also how she
wound up landing white lotus which has
now given her like another yeah phase of
her career that's so cool like we love
women supporting women and it's cool
that jennifer like acknowledges it as
like this turning point in her career
for like a comeback yeah jennifer
college is just everything i've never
really seen american pie really i've
seen bits of it but no i've definitely
seen the first one i wasn't like
watching all of them but i think i
probably like watching a cable when i
was a kid like once i know people are
going to like cancel me for never having
seen it but it's just like a little
young i think american pie movies are
like definitely like
oh so that cancels each other they
definitely don't age well you know
interesting
we're just like a little for when it
came out we were a little young to be
watching it so isn't it like more
targeted towards boys yeah i think it
was like for teens and like that girl
was in it you know like the girl this
one time of band camp that's her right
like from um lily from how i met your
mother
tara reid also yeah
definitely tara reid i haven't heard
that name in forever i hope she's doing
well like truly honestly deeply deeply
madly
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is something that is not
doing well oh my god our fifth and final
story already yep well we go slow we go
fast we just can't get it together
our fifth and final story is brought to
you by uh air doctor oh we gotta get an
air doctor down here we do i have one
here oh okay clean air is one of the
fastest and easiest ways we can have a
positive impact on our health improve
the quality of your indoor air quality
with a high quality air purifier and all
you have to do is breathe so if you're
managing asthma or allergies
certain steps can be taken to ensure
indoor air quality is healthy so you
gotta check out air doctor when you're
breathing twenty thousand breaths per
day air doctor is gonna filter out
dangerous contaminants and allergens so
your lungs don't have to air doctor uses
an ultra hepa filter that's been
independently tested to remove 99.99 of
bacteria and viruses so americans are
spending 90 of our time indoors and
according to the epa indoor air can be
two to five times more polluted than
outdoor air so with the air doctor
they're taking care of it and there's no
need to worry about the noise they use
exclusively professional whisper jet
fans that are 30 quieter than quieter
than the fans found in ordinary air
purifiers it means you can run air
doctor at the highest speed while still
enjoying a peaceful home environment
we've got air doctors in our homes in
our new york studio we got to bring one
up here it is just an easy way to make
sure like you're being taken care of
especially if you have asthma or
allergies i have neither but i just
still find it's like a visible
difference in like my quality of like
breath um an air doctor is premium like
invest in a good
purifier within a few days of getting
air doctor you will notice
nasal congestion snot coughing sneezing
itchy nose and watery eyes are gone they
come with the no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantee so if you don't
love it just send it back for a refund
minus the shipping head to
airdoctorpro.com and use code toast and
depending on the model you'll receive up
to 35 off that's up to 35 off but only
if you go to a-i-r-d-o-c-t-o-r
dot com use promo code toast
airdoctorpro.com
promo code toast
okay great our fifth and final story
some movie news that's kind of crazy the
batgirl movie has been shelved canceled
not happening despite spending 70
million dollars on it and it's done okay
who was supposed to be batgirl that girl
was supposed to be um leslie grace she's
from in the heights but also uh it was
pretty star-studded um who what's that
guy's name from whiplash jk simmons was
in it i love him uh michael keaton like
reprises his role for a little bit
brendan fraser is the villain
not brandon frazier the love of my life
yeah so they spent 70 million dollars on
the movie and they actually went over by
a lot of millions and they finished it
and they were
done they were yeah it's done and they
weren't like she the star was even like
talking about in interviews like it was
about so weird
and it like tested so badly
that that's one reason why they are just
pulling it it's not even going directly
to dvd i mean just not happening they
put out such bad movies that if this one
was too bad to release i cannot imagine
how bad it was i think also even though
it was done and put i think actually
putting it out would tarnish the brand
and it's such a prestigious brand that
like they actually are just
flushing the money down the toilet okay
i also have like an extremely hot take
about like taking like famous roles and
making them female you mean jamie bond
yes everyone's like we need a female
james bond we need a famous um a fame
uh female
batman the only supergirl is different
because supergirl actually like exists
like korea i'm like i'm i'm saying like
taking
roles that are famous
and male and making them female like i'm
so
not here for that first of all it feels
like a handout like oh we need to give
like a special movie for the girls
because they're like dumb and stupid
like it just feels like so like
embarrassing and it's like okay instead
of making
a spin-off of like like the melissa
benoist tv show
like it was just like cringy like why
don't you just create more original
roles that are female centered like
instead of just giving us like handouts
right original roles and also like
something like background like i really
do think the majority of the audience
for dc movies like are men
that's not true
i know what you're going to say i don't
think that's true and also like female
superheroes even if it is like a
male-centric audience like they love it
no and they do perform well like brie
larson right but they i don't think like
the marvel audience like likes like and
i don't know i'm not like a marvel girly
but at least for me like i just see from
the outside i'm like okay you want to
get more more women involved like write
original roles for women instead of
being like it's batman but a girl batman
being a man or a woman doesn't make me
want to see batman any more or less yeah
yeah i will happen to see it if someone
has it put on in my living room yeah i
can't remember a time in recent history
or like memory where
a movie doesn't get released that's like
so weird so weird especially like
something so big budget
yeah
i wonder like what there's like tea
there it says me more than that
definitely tea there there was also um
they were citing like organizational
changes within like dc warner brothers
whatever and like the new person
who's the head of something is pretty
uh budget-conscious and they would need
to spend even more millions marketing in
this like it would be another 30 to 50
million and it's bad as opposed to just
like swallowing the loss yeah you know
i'm i think that's probably the right
choice but that's just crazy i can't
even it's crazy i can't recall a movie
that never came out you're right they
usually like do like sad to dvd like on
demand give it away for free right
pretend like
release it and not really talk about it
even like and
even with movies like with like remember
after kevin spacey he had done a few
movies and they were like here watch
them or don't right like very low-key
release
yeah
yeah
huh
well that's like the movie we just
watched death on the nile like the army
hammer that was like right with army
hammer there wasn't a ton of promotion
and it was like a decently good movie
but it never got like the fanfare
because they were like embarrassed to
have worked with army you think it was i
never even saw a commercial for it
i had seen some promo i thought it was
because it didn't get like really good
reviews
the movie was good enough it wasn't a
bad movie it wasn't as good as the
it wasn't as good as the original what
was the original
agatha christie well not an original
just a different out of the thing that's
pretty cool murder um
but it's not a prequel you know what i
mean it's like the same chapter
it's the same yeah
so it was it was a fine movie like there
was no reason to like hide the release
unless they were ashamed of working with
cannibalist army hammer right but
still so many movies even they when they
have like a cancelled person in post
they just go forth you know do they like
west side story
yeah but like that's okay that's a
really interesting example because west
side story of course stars a canceled
person but like
for some reason hollywood is like not
like keeping up with ansel al gore like
they like are acting like they don't
know what we're talking about
because so he's not canceled like i
think uh the america would say yes but i
think like he's still getting you know
roles and brand deals like i think his
life remains pretty much unaffected
interesting i think yeah
i don't know it's definitely been a
little hush-hush i feel like he's like
waiting still he's in the holding period
yeah but he's still like working
actively yeah so that's a good example
um those are the past five stories feel
as though you needed to know them what
happened to batgirl if you have any tea
let us know yeah no i'm definitely
curious because that's like
it's interesting and even though there
are definitely like was organizational
changes that like change the way like dc
movies are made now whatever you don't
throw away 70 million a whole film yes
it's a hot piece of garbage yeah i guess
we have to see it i now i would love to
see it no no maybe this is a press thing
because now i'm intrigued yeah i don't
even know there was going to be a
batgirl no me neither now i am intrigued
how bad could a movie be and like why is
it batman and then batgirl like what
about bat grown ass woman
young girl you know i'm telling you
there's something really [ __ ] like
weird about this that's nasty that's so
true yeah bat child like it's weird no
like it's girls like
girls are kids yeah women
bat lady
i like a lady
something fat chick um
that [ __ ]
those are the fast five stories that was
our thursday episode we're back tomorrow
with the final episode of the week and
remember if your name is rachel
get your ass up get your [ __ ] ass up
and go over to youtube and start
subscribing
if you want to see me on tour next
no if you want to see me on tour period
tomorrow 10 a.m local time
girlwithnojob.com tickets are going on
sale
anything you want oh new episode of the
redheads new episode of the redhead so
miss it even if you didn't read the book
it's fine we recap the book at the
beginning and then we talk about it
throughout so you won't miss a beat
thank you so much for listening to the
morning to us the millennial morning
show where we reach over the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts and we're podcasting outside
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places so
whenever you listen to podcasts find out
some morning chelsea 5 star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing thursday
and we'll see you tomorrow for
friday friday
gotta get down on friday oh that's so
exciting goodbye goodbye